puces et le dossier de la transmission
du virus du sida par transfusion
sanguine c'est donc vous le constatez
alourdi ce week-end ce soir le
professeur jean lloyd ancien président
de la fondation de transfusion sanguine
et actuel adjoint au maire de paris a
demandé son inculpation aux côtés de
michel garretta le professeur jean log
souhaite donner sa version des faits
dans le contexte de l'époque
c'est-à-dire en 84 85 et tout à l'heure
c'était sur l'a5 et en direct chez jean
pierre elkabbach à 19 heures le docteur
michel garretta s'est vigoureusement
défendu xavier baunat eu
40 minutes pour parler enfin 40 minutes
pour se défendre des accusations portées
contre lui 40 minutes d'un plaidoyer
sérieux presque pathétique première
étape le docteur garetta reconnaît sa
responsabilité
des erreurs et je me reconnais responsa
je l' ai toujours dit y compris au juge
dès la première fois je l' ai vu ce que
par contre je n'accepte pas c'est
qu'aujourd'hui une conspiration du
silence conspiration du silence celle de
tous les experts dit il qui ensemble ont
pris les décisions sans aucune voix
discordante
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont conseillé au
ministère de la santé et au centre
national la politique qui a été mise en
oeuvre la politique a été mise en oeuvre
si quelqu'un aujourd'hui à dire qu'il
fallait faire autrement et s'il savait à
l'époque il est coupable ne n'avoir rien
dit mais ne l'a pas dit à moi et le
docteur garetta de constater que
l'erreur est mondiale
il n'y a pas la france qui est un milieu
au noir avec des gens incompétents et
des gens insouciants il ya une réalité
mondiale et tous les pays où les emf ils
sont traités ont dû faire face à
saint-etienne vient lui michel garretta
informe-t-il le gouvernement ou la
direction générale de la santé du danger
des produits sanguins pour hémophiles
en avril 1985 j'écris au ministère de la
santé pour leur dire ou à la ce qui se
passe je suis probablement le seul à
l'avoir fait quand on regarde toutes les
pièces disponibles donc le seul dans
toute la france jeudi voilà ce qui se
passe voilà ce qu'on va faire je
recommence et j'écris au mois de mai au
ministère de la santé au laboratoire
national de la santé je dis voilà la
situation pour la sq on envisage de
faire alors qui est responsable
pour michel garretta tous les acteurs de
la transfusion
moi je dis que tous les acteurs la
clinique bien les gens de la transfusion
les scientifiques les responsables
administratives les politiques ont tous
une part de responsabilité il faut
aujourd'hui avoir le courage de
reconnaître chacun notre part de
responsabilité sans vouloir accuser
quelqu'un d'autre il ya un drame qui est
suffisamment compliquée à gérer c'est
pas en recherchant à dire que quelqu'un
coupable alors que c'est une
responsabilité collective consentir à 40
minutes d'entretien pour ne plus passer
pour le méchant
cette forme d'explication qui est
choisie nous devons être plusieurs
dizaines voire plusieurs centaines 40
minutes d'entretien pour ne plus passer
pour le méchant docteur garetta
aura-t-il convaincu